une autre monde c'est squeeze
aujourd'hui on se retrouve de nouveau
sur god simulator parce que je pense
être passé a coûté pas mal de trucs la
dernière fois et que j'ai envie de
rejouer à ce jeu complètement barré
c'est parti c'est quoi ça est-ce qu'on
peut pas s'attacher à lui
non on pourrait carrément croire que ça
na li mal qu'un train de danser ça là où
les petites mèches de cheveux mais non
je veux aller dans ce [ __ ] de
conteneurs on va tenter un truc s'il te
plaît pousse-toi corps de chèvre or de
chièvres laisse beauvoir voilà où c'est
ce qui va nous permettre d'aller dans le
contraire il ya comme quelque chose
entre vous sauvaître les couilles j'ai
dit ah quand même quelque chose entre
vous j'ai dit au coach
aucune réaction de la part de hawaii à
voile à l'exorciste encore une fois et
non pas à celle de merde pétition
oh oui ça suffit ce n'est pas une liane
c'est ta langue unique baby les nuls
pour la peine je vais pas me fuir mais
[ __ ] mais je suis juste que tu vas
dans la gueule je sais faut faire péter
le camion voilà tu étais sûr attention
madame quoi qu'il arrive elle reste
debout
ah bah voilà
ragdoll skate c'est ridicule ouais
[Musique]
ah ah oh
cette vue là est ce que cette chose
j'essaie de me parlez pas du tout
j'avais juste toucher les faibles cette
chèvre c'est quoi ce truc
oh je vais lâcher ma colère sur ses
cartons jeu très vilaine chèvre la sait
pas où on allait
on va le tenter attention le feld en
titre opère saloperies oculaire je
savais regardez le là alors c'est
comment va on va lui montrer notre temps
faut que je prenne une arme avec moi toi
alain olio ensemble je demande à tel
point que google sait pas que je t'ai
mais pas avant la voilà en plus tu tu as
koupèla clos devant ce parfait non
ah désolé avons interrompu votre
complément aux mille et une statue seul
à à la clarinette qui s'éclate
[Musique]
oui oui oh oui oh mon gars non pour la
statuette
oui c'est beau oui c'est une victoire
fondatrice type à 12 ans vers d'autres
cieux
ça fait ok pour amener des mecs [ __ ]
hilton cheyrou au milieu
est ce qu'on peut en kidnappé un
discrètement
[Musique]
c'est bon c'est pas le moment de faire
le pont ok on y retourne c'est normal
non il sert il s'est rien passé je te
jure donc de moyens pas comme ça allez
tu viens non bientôt des permutations
avec la chaise mettons ça la beta test
spécial air des maudits
what excuse et une chèvre ou une
araignée boîte ouais bon jour allez
viens de te couches pas des machines
foule
what a un look and feel the goat c'est
quoi la petite info dont marie l'heure
de la revanche a sonné ok cet appel ok
stop
qu'est ce que tu fais là à toi ta partie
aval fille à contre jour
je suis un chèvre un peu araignée mais
un peu chez brault si elle est lui à
chaque fois ils tapent des esquives mais
c'est inhumain
1 voilà toujours debout sur la boule tôt
à settat punition alors est-ce que top
ça un beach non n'imite pas le coton
tige ça suffit c'est l'heure de tester
la fida go ça rien d'une chienne assez
monstrueux je veux te picorer howie à
l'aube sans aller au 120 est la langue
de la chaîne eloignez-vous de support
that what arrestation pour faire sinon
y'a pas de deux cores rigole j'ai une
sorte de lacets de chaussures un peu je
suis tout flasque
qu'est ce qu'il fait lui encore un
accouplement devant j'en ai marre et
maintenant ils passent au mur avec ça
suffit
il s'est passé quoi prendre moment là je
sens qu'il ya des maisons peut rentrer
mary en cachette un genre celle ci non
oh c'est beau une autruche qui veulent
quand même mais non ça suffit
thonnel je pense l'échec elle joue
annonce dh / truc quoi espèce de hareth
j'ai bon je les veux ton cul l'autruche
là ça suffit je suis seul je trouve ça
assez discret et pauvre tu as nous irons
à dont je vais rentrer dans ce trou
laissez moi au moins mon cou s'il vous
plaît mon cours entre regard des cheveux
du pain à l'émotion modo respecte moi
c'est pas aux blessures les fais ce que
tu me respectes mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
impuissante large des ses pattes
accrochés aux escales et l'eau dessus
ce groupe de chefs qui sort du mur
[ __ ] c'est quoi ça gold castle c'est
quoi ce délire
oh [ __ ] des objets en or on prend on
se casse rôle eux ont le franc et on se
casse tout ce qu'ils adopteront une
posture non parfaite ce verrou châtié de
mes cordes
c'est à dire vous tous au top laissez
moi prendre place sur ce coup boîte au
sa grande nouvelle fièvre je peux faire
apparaître des chefs c'est tout ce que
je voulais c'est scandaleux
j'appelle mes confrères tout de suite
ouais
ok c'est bon tu peux partir et à bagnols
ya aucun problème apparemment maintenant
si je veux rentrer dans ce magasin
quelle est cette discrimination l'espoir
rentrée tu veux que je t'emmène quelque
part tu as tu fait beaucoup d'effet et
tu sais c'est quoi ce délire au coach
c'est quand m
for you bad wahaha au dessus je suis
menacé sur le banc au yes j'en étais sûr
j'en étais sûr bon ben là les gens c'est
déjà pas de cette vidéo sur cote
et si je me devais de pâques
j'ai tout gâché bon bah voilà les gens
c'est déjà fin de cette deuxième vidéo
sur goltv latorre j'espère que ça ne
sera plus si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo ça me fera vraiment
plaisir et puis je pense qu'on en a fini
pour gold simulator c'était assez
marrant d'ailleurs jeune femme en outre
aux tiens à tout le monde
beach
[Musique]
m
il est
[Musique]